you can't wear a Chuck Norris shirt
Chuck Norris wears you and the world's
largest gummy worm it's episode two of
loot marshmallow guns are sweet but not
for someone of your stature what you
deserve is cool materials
double-barreled marshmallow crossbow
want to buy some Hello Kitty sushi will
use the Hello Kitty sushi roll kit it
comes with instructions and special
molds just be sure to eat it with some
of these unique chopsticks lightsabres
sauce dispensers these which are good
for Americans and okay that's just a
rice bowl bra after digestion you may as
well have some fun so clean up with this
origami toilet paper and if you want to
clean up even more Etsy user Digital
soaps offers soap in the shape of a
Super Nintendo controller
it smells like sour apple candy but his
PlayStation 3 shaped controller soap
will make you smell and I'm not kidding
like Mountain Dew if you still got
issues you might need to buy some
underneath these Underpants filter and
subdue your own farts they're
practically airtight with that much
confidence you should rest easy so grab
a pair of these pixelated sleeping masks
this hoodie says high five
but if you unzip it a little bit it says
live long and prosper
and here's a hoodie that zips up to look
like Mario and zips down to make you
Mario pajama jeans are only the
beginning keep your eyes open for bikini
jeans and these not yet for sale jeans
that turn your lap into a wireless
keyboard but now let's look at some mice
ones a hamburger ones a heart and this
one is coated with a material to kill
bacteria but if that's not clean enough
for you get this mouse which can be
washed in the sink now some of you may
be saying look Michael I like my mice
dirty well in that case get this bikini
Mouse Bob Bassett makes some really
awesome stuff like a scary leather
bulldog mask and a knife carved out of
sapphire that won't set off metal
detectors he's only selling a few things
on eBay right now but I'm holding out
for another dragon backpack back to
knives DIY with the Orvis knife making
kit it comes with a blade a block of
wood to carve a handle reindeer hide
leather for making the sheath and a
spacer made out of an actual reindeer
antler with a knife like that you should
be able to carve an app
like this artist Kevin Vaughn all snakes
the kind of clever art I love Hawaiian
Punch spilled in the shape of Hawaii
human innards made with chewed-up bubble
gum a replica of his thumbprint made out
of Cheetos or this one made with his
cat's poop if you're lucky you can find
prints for sale like this one game time
creation areas like pictionary except
instead of drawing the clues you have to
build them with Legos as your teammates
guess what you're making and here's a
Rubik's Cube where every block is the
same color but each row is a different
size which means this can easily
discombobulated into this I will give
you today with cute cuddly plushies of
gross microbes be sure to subscribe to
Vsauce 2 for more and let me know below
what you would like to have a stuffed
animal version of thanks for watching
[Music]